thank you guys we are indeed with a
legend of american uh chess mr goreevich
welcome to the show welcome back uh to
st louis uh tell us a bit about your
experience so far in the tournament oh
i'm i'm i'm very happy to be here the
players in my tournament i know them for
for a very long time
since the 80s
and 90s
so it's wonderful to be here and to
watch them i learn i learn from young
players also
they're very good
absolutely a
slow start at the beginning you were
maybe you know it was that for me no
it was a very good start because i was
probably in a bad position say
completely lost in round one in wet
position in every game at some point so
for me it's not a slow start you managed
to survive in the other one and finally
uh you actually took over in this game
tell us a bit about this game
well igor navika was a very famous
player and he very rarely loses so i i
wasn't expecting this result that's
pretty much amazing results for me uh
and it was always very interesting to to
play this game prepare for him you know
so he's more or less plays the same
openings so uh being very very strong uh
he
used to be a great politician in that
thing
and now he he probably knows all the
openings he played but this one maybe he
he didn't play for a few years so
it was my lucky chance did he surprise
you with this triangle set up or
not well prepared for that he played it
before i was choosing some things
against it and
um if i
go for example he offers you to play
normal uh semi slav defense
and
uh that one he he knows one of the best
in the world he's used used to be like
couple a few years ago so he knows it
all
uh and and this one uh it's position
which allows you if you if you
different ways to play
one classical move with bishop d2 and
but i prefer knight
it doesn't give too much but but you got
this position and
i think
right where yasser was with the two
bishops
it is it is a good position i think he
made a little bit of an accuracy because
he he didn't have to
probably castle too early but this
position i saw in advance and then you
have to make very exact moves if i you
make one but move yeah quintiful is
dubious i'm i'm glad to see that because
i didn't know what to do i was uh
considering certain certain moves like
queen h4h4 and i didn't see anything
particularly good bishop a7 doesn't do
too much in my opinion i'm not sure it
wasn't that much or g4 or something yeah
but i am not sure what's going on i'm
i'm pretty curious myself well queen to
d4 is not a bad move it's just
this is the queen of five is a very bad
move i saw it but
i i'm sure white is better but how much
better i don't know so 95 probably
it's the move to consider uh the main
move and then uh i would have played
right away i'm not sure maybe bishop b6
was one of them sorry to interrupt you
dimitri we have yeah it's i can't wait
in
and i do think uh
larry won that game right yes larry won
against uh maxim he was better he was
better a little bit but in the opening i
thought he was winning completely but
then i realized no probably not max is a
good defender also yeah but this is a
probably this is a move yeah so
yeah this this means for black but for
white but i'm not sure
if i did everything right i mean i
played the most conservative
move
and this is very good position yes i
have to play c5 and after that
position is winning but uh if you make
mistake you know yeah
it wasn't not i think the best thing to
do was not to give a check
but to play c6 right away yeah this is
this is probably he has a little bit you
felt like you're giving him some chances
yeah definitely but it's a old
expression the parts receives a check he
gives it
yeah so this is a position when i was
expecting
to play at some point no this is winning
but could he play something like queen
d6 maybe that was okay ns7 i'm not sure
so
i i think it's one position but it's not
not easy at all i mean if he plays the
correct move
[Music]
maybe one move earlier a little bit but
king d6 queen to d8 that should be
winning uh
yeah so what is the queen queen d3 yeah
this is what he played yes he played can
you see
okay okay another queen to f
okay so maybe here queen to f5 is that
yes it's possible yes this is it and
then
can he play
king e8
no then c7 no it looks winning it looks
winning more or less yeah he doesn't
have time to get the queen to d6 it
seems like yes yes
it is it looks like it's uh yeah here
for me if i go for for uh the endgame
this extra pawn it's very good drawing
chances absolutely yes but this one
gives me a lot of options
uh
to how to play and it's very position
you can you can
choose different plans more or less safe
which should be winning but
of course end game is always
some amazing things happen well
the imagery are confident victory i have
to say congratulations guys any
questions
no just our congratulations uh like you
were surprised you had such bad
positions dima
and uh
you had such a bad position
look
very bad yeah yeah plus score is very
nice hey bad positions but no bad
results so you can't complain about that
plus i cannot complain about anything
keep up keep up the good work
absolutely and by the way the seniors
have been very very slow
in terms